limited municipal capacity to navigate
funding programs available
we've also
published an accompanying data file that
allows users to quickly sort programs
funded under the law by fields like
agency amount recipient
or program name to make it easy as easy
as humanly possible with that zeke
thanks jen uh sort of starting with uh
tensions between russia and ukraine we
heard in the last couple of days from
some ukrainian government officials
minimizing or downplaying the imminence
of the potential russian invasion that
seems to be disconnected between
washington
is there concerns in washington that
talking up the russian threat is in fact
weakening the ukrainian government
well i can only speak for
our intention and our responsibility and
we feel it's important to be open and
candid about the threat from russia it's
not just words of course you are seeing
specifics uh that we've been laying out
here including over 100 000 troops on
ukraine's borders amassed on the border
with more troops and weaponry on the way
uh they've also been serving troops into
belarus which our u.n ambassador spoke
about this morning seeing about five a
surge of 5 000 troops in belarus with
plans for more in the coming weeks we're
also seeing russia undertake efforts to
destabilize ukraine including through a
possible false flag operation it's
dangerous we've been saying for more
than a week that russia could invade at
any time
i would note though that
our effort is to ensure we're informing
the american public and the global
community of the seriousness of this
threat even as we work with the
ukrainians with the europeans to ensure
we are not only preparing them and
providing them supplies that they need
but standing up and making clear to the
russians what the consequences will be
so i can't speak to the uh motivation or
the reasoning for the comments of
ukrainian leadership i can only speak to
what our efforts are here and uh is
there any discussions underway in
washington providing some economic
stabilization to the ukrainian
government
and another sort of domestic concern
as this sort of
stalemate continues right now additional
economic assistance beyond humanitarian
assistance or other economic assistance
we've provided
uh i'm not aware of that but i can check
and see if there's more specifics from
our team
capitol hill
bipartisan uh legislation that has been
coming through uh pretty quickly uh that
would include potentially preemptive
sanctions uh against russia ahead of a
potential invasion of further invasion
is that something the president is
willing to uh to sign into law should
have passed well we are working very
closely with congress on uh on you on
ukraine and russia and the tensions
we're seeing build up at the border
we've briefed you on the number of
conversations we've had both in a
classified and unclassified format and
we've also had a range of conversations
about this legislation we certainly are
encouraged by the fact that there's
bipartisan discussions about how to hold
russia accountable how to
have a deterrent impact
our view is that sanctions can be an
effective tool of deterrence and the
deepening sell-off in russian markets
reflects our message our message to uh
russia uh but we are uh in these
conversations uh with congress and we
look forward to continuing those
on a different topic we heard a few
minutes ago from governor hutchinson uh
calling on uh the cdc and the federal
government to provide more
uh clearer guidance for the american
republic as copenhagen moves from the
pandemic stage to a more endemic virus
that we all have to live with for some
time
can you speak a little bit how does is
that something the president uh believes
as well and is there a disconnect
between
the white house's messaging for
americans that they should go about
you know take precautions that they can
go about their daily lives in its midst
of this omicron search particularly if
they're vaccinated and boosted and also
the precautions that are taken because
the president is the president you know
the distance between him and the
governors
uh you know not going to dinner last
night with the other government things
of that sort well i would say first
there are a number of precautions that
we have long taken uh from the white
house and around the president and vice
president which i think is to be
expected he still participated in the
event last night the president's view
which i think you heard him speak to in
his press conference just about 10 days
ago is that uh covid and our efforts to
address covet are not going to exist in
this current uh world we're living in
now this is not the new normal what
we're living in in this moment and
that's important for the public to
understand because right now we're
seeing record hospitalizations uh you
know we are seeing uh we are still
living with a range of precautions that
uh change how people live their lives um
and in the president's view that is not
uh that is not a living with covet in a
way that it doesn't disrupt your life
given we're still dealing with surges
across the country uh it is also true as
you heard him talk about and this is
where i don't think there's a disconnect
maybe it's a maybe it's the use of words
that we have a range of tools that we
had did not have a year ago right um and
this is something we've obviously been
in close discussion with governors about
uh whether it is of course the fact that
more than 87 of the uh of the um country
adults are having received at least one
dose or the fact that we've just ordered
a huge supply of of pills that is a game
changer in many ways or that we have
masks that are now being distributed
across the country and and tests as well
so we are in a very different place um i
don't think we see it as a disconnect uh
the president's view is that uh right
now we still need to keep our heads down
and stay at it to fight what is uh still
uh you know surging in parts of the
country but we do have the tools uh to
get to a point where it does not disrupt
our daily lives
uh can you give us any update on the
president's search for supreme court
nominee uh he mentioned he's gonna be
having in-person meetings here at the
white house is that something that might
begin this week
uh yes i can give you an update um
so um as you have heard um
the president say uh he is
he will do his duty to select a justice
not only with the senate's consent but
with its advice as somebody who served
on the senate uh judiciary committee and
was chair both as chair and ranking
member he's steeped in this process and
looks forward to advice from members of
both parties on the hill as well as top
legal experts and scholars across the
country working with the vice president
and his team at the white house and i
think you will see those consultations
start this week so tomorrow the
president is going to host chairman
durbin and ranking member grassley at
the white house to consult with them and
hear their advice about this vacancy
chairman durbin has worked on seven
supreme court
confirmation processes the president has
also worked for many years with senator
grassley and respects his knowledge
and views so this will be part of that
process and i expect we'll have more uh
details to confirm as the week proceeds
the president has said he's going to be
you know reaching across the aisle
obviously as he makes this decision we
heard over the weekend senator lindsey
graham supporting his fellow south
carolinian judge j michelle childs is
bipartisan support a must-have for this
president or uh something that he would
truly like to have
well i think one we appreciate senator
graham's thoughts on the president is
working hard to choose from a wealth of
deeply qualified candidates who bring to
bear the strongest records credentials
and abilities that anyone could have for
this role i think as the president views
it uh what's his his objective and his
intention is to choose from among a a
group of
of black women with impeccable uh an
impeccable record
impeccable records and impeccable
credential credentials and he expects
the senate democrats and republicans to
consider the qualifications
of these nominees and do that as it has
been done historically for many decades
in the past um so uh we certainly expect
and he has every intention of nominating
somebody who with impeccable credentials
and certainly we expect and are hopeful
that uh republicans will look seriously
at whomever he nominates uh and uh at
what they who who they are and what they
what they would bring to the court and
just one more on this um our latest poll
shows that just over three quarters of
americans 76
want the president to consider all
possible nominees not only black women
as he pledged on the campaign trail um
what do you make of this and why do you
think that a majority of americans want
the president to take a different
approach here
well again what we can assure the
american public of um whether wherever
they fell on that poll is that uh he
will choose uh and nominate uh someone
who has impeccable credentials and is
eminently qualified uh to serve uh as a
supreme court justice and someone who is
eminently qualified to serve in a
lifetime appointment he did make a
promise
to the country
that's certainly how he sees it and he's
going to work hard on this choice
seeking advice and counsel from as i
noted earlier a range of leaders of
experts um and that's something that he
is already pursuing uh this week i would
note that there's a long history here
president reagan promised the country he
would nominate the country's first woman
to serve on the court and he did so
former president trump also promised to
choose a woman
just over a year ago and there was no
such complaint from the voices on the
right who are speaking out now but the
president's commitment
is to
deliver on the promise he made to the
country but he has there's no question
in his mind that there is a wealth of
qualified talented uh black women to
choose from in this uh to to nominate go
ahead
can you talk a little more about the
size of the pool of candidates that the
president will be considering we've
heard a lot about a few names that are
currently federal judges the president
had appointed but then we've seen some
expanding lists could you quantify that
to any degree and are all of these women
being actively considered for the
vacancy or might it also include future
federal positions that the president
would also have the power to appoint
well um what i can this may be
unsatisfying i will just preface for you
um kelly which i hate to do but um you
know as somebody who uh appreciates the
solemn importance of the responsibility
he has um he's of course been reviewing
a number of potential candidates
that is a list
that is bigger than a few in the number
of bios that he has been looking for
looking at um and that have been
prepared for him by his team in order to
be prepared if a vacancy occurred
we don't think and he it is important to
him to preserve um the details of the
process uh and his intention is to as
you know put forward a nominee next
month so this is not a month many months
long process he is very focused on it
and committed to it but we're not going
to get into details of names uh
if we can avoid it
or details of numbers at this point in
time often for this kind of process
there is a team appointed to work short
term inside the white house to be sort
of a guide for that nominee
the term of art in washington is sure
have you made any progress on that we've
been making progress uh and expect we'll
have more to announce for all of you
hopefully soon last question do you
think bipartisanship the chance to get
republican votes
would be a factor that would weigh
heavily on the president among those he
would consider
i think the president is going to select
a woman a black woman who is qualified
who is prepared who has impeccable
experience to serve on the court
he's going to do that based on her
credentials of course having a
discussion with her and not through
gaming out the system he believes that
democrats and republicans should
seriously and carefully consider
any qualified nominee he puts forward as
he has done in the past himself
good oh sorry i'll come back to your
jacket
thank you uh the members of the economic
team have been sort of running the jobs
number on friday
saying that uh the the figure could be
one of course of all the omicron cases
we had during the sample period i'm
wondering what your expectation or the
white house signification for
this report uh
is and in particular we've had a lot of
revisions of these reports in recent
months do you think it's time to
overhaul
how the department of labor does this
survey the methodology that kind of
thing
i have no prediction or call for any uh
uh changes to how the process is run but
what i can tell you is we're looking in
preparation for the friday jobs numbers
uh we'll get the monthly jobs report of
course
for january on friday the way the jobs
numbers are calculated is every month um
is there there it is calculated every
month it's a little complicated but
there are some simple things here to
understand that most people don't
realize if a worker was out sick during
the week the survey was taken because
it's the data is taken over a week and
that is that is what the monthly jobs
number is based on and did not receive
paid leave they are counted as having
lost their job now that isn't an
accurate depiction and this is why i
think you're asking the second question
of whether or not they were unemployed
but that's how it's calculated
because omicron was so highly
transmissible nearly 9 million people
called out sick in early january when
the jobs data was being collected so
during that same period of time and the
week the survey was taken the week of
january 12th was at the height of the
omicron spike so we just wanted to kind
of prepare
you know people to understand how the
data is taken what they're looking at
and what it is an assessment of and as
as a result the month's jobs report may
show job losses in large part because
workers were out sick from omicron at
the point when it was peaking during the
period when the week where the data was
taken
the president's uh distancing and events
is it fair for us to interpret that this
is a precaution being taken given the
case loads we're seeing in particular in
dc but other places is he is he taking
more steps to not sit within six feet
for instance of people that he had been
previously it was it's not a new
precaution uh we have had a process and
it it may look different when people are
sitting down right because we don't do
as many events with people seated versus
standing but when somebody has their
mask off we make a special effort
because because they're speaking to
ensure that that spacing is adequate
applies to the president and the vice
president for instance other people
spoke today but we're shoulder to
shoulder so we're just wondering if
there's a particular rule for the vp
uh i know that's a precaution we try to
take around them i can certainly see if
there's more specifics of additional
speakers finally can you see if there's
any update on the buildback better
negotiations but is that a fair word for
them is that ongoing
you say whether the president has spoken
recently with senator manchin or senator
cinema
i'm not going to give any details uh on
any conversations he's had uh per our
policy of uh trying to keep those
conversations private i will say that
there are is still a great deal of
interest passion i might say uh and
advocacy on the hill uh for moving
forward uh with uh with uh build back
better agenda because uh there's a
recognition and understanding that it's
long overdue
for congress to take steps to lower
costs
on for child care lower costs for elder
care
negotiate the price of prescription
drugs
and and ask higher income companies and
americans to pay more those are all also
widely popular among the public so right
now the point we're at is there's a lot
of discussion among members their staffs
committees we're engaged in those as
well about what big chunk just to keep
using the phrase um we can uh we can
agree on moving forward and of course
that would require 50 votes but those
conversations are always ongoing thank
you oh good jackie thank you jen
um
real quick on crime first um i wanted to
ask about uh there was an appearance to
your appearance in policy of america
there was a discussion of
fox's crime coverage um and one line has
prompted some criticism um from people
it was um
stopped on crime consequences what even
is that um were you speaking in your
personal opinion or is that at all um
a reflection of the priorities of this
administration
because the criticism is that um it
would reflect that crime is not a
priority of this administration well i
encourage anyone to listen to the full
context of the interview and the
conversation what i was speaking to was
a chiron on fox news since you raised it
which suggested this administration is
soft on crime with no basis given we
have had many conversations and back and
forth with you and your colleagues about
the prioritization of the president to
ensure that we are working as close
partners with leaders whether it is
mayor adams who he is going to spend the
day with on thursday or others in the
country and the facts speak for
themselves this is what i was talking
about in the interview for the full
context
in the american rescue plan there was
additional funding to support local cops
programs something that every single
republican voted against i said in that
interview that i know they don't like it
when we call that out i'm going to keep
calling that out because that's a fact
also president biden has proposed a
significant increase in funding for
local cops programs in his budget more
than the prior president that's a fact
so
if those facts are uncomfortable i'm
sorry for people who feel they need to
be critical but the president has been a
long time advocate of addressing crime
he's never been for defunding the police
our department of justice has increased
funding has put in place support for
strike forces and the other fact that is
never talked about in these fox packages
maybe than this one is the fact that gun
crime is a major driver of crime across
the country also a fact so those are
pieces i think in that moment i was
speaking to and again we're about the
facts here and addressing crime is
something that is a root of the
president's agenda i appreciate that and
then i want to move on to
the doj there is a letter from tom
cotton today
threatening to block the president's doj
nominees over um the department of
justice
allegedly denying four deputy u.s
marshals legal defense in lawsuits
stemming from the portland riots is the
white house aware of this and can you
give us an explanation for why that
would be happening i'm not aware of the
specifics of it jackie i'm happy to
check with our counsel's office i assume
and see if there's something more
specific we can get back to you thank
you and then on um there's there's been
this leaked video of border patrol
agents
expressing frustration over some of the
policies of this administration i know
that we talked last week about flights
and we've heard the explanation for this
procedure that they were
frustrated over
but this video
seems to show that that morel is
you know in a tough place that these
agents are frustrated
who are having to carry out these
policies is anything being done
to improve morale is there going to be
any sort of outreach from the
administration to border patrol given
that we're seeing more of this come to
the surface
i haven't watched in detail the video i
will note that i think it was the
migrant flights video is that the one
that was or is it it's a different video
okay um i didn't want to speak to the
wrong thing um of course uh the role
that border patrol agents play um in
ensuring security and safety at our
borders is something that there's great
value for in this administration i would
point you the department of homeland
security who oversees of course the the
border patrol agents and can see if
there's anything any more specific
programs that are underway um go ahead
jeff thank you thank you follow to
kelly's question about trying to
quantify the pool of special supreme
court nominee yeah a white house
official told us late friday that the
reporting in some outlets that there
were three primary contenders that that
was incorrect i wonder then for our
reporting would it be more accurate to
say a dozen dozens plural
women under consideration i understand
your efforts i appreciate them i value
them um but i can tell you that the
president feels very strongly about
ensuring we're protecting the process
what i was getting at with kelly a
little bit let me be a little more clear
is that the number of bios and
information that the president has been
reviewing was greater than the three
okay
on voting rights what's the the
president's view on the early bipartisan
talks around uh rewriting reforming the
electoral count act it doesn't go nearly
as far as he'd wanted on voting rights
but there is perhaps new urgency given
the former president's comments at that
rally and in the statement where he
uh appeared to admit to this scheme to
overturn the election results of 2020.
sure well let me speak to that first and
then i'll come around to the um
electoral count act um
so in terms of the former president his
actions uh represented a unique and
existential threat to our democracy as
the president has said many times but
you know his remarks this weekend he
defended the actions of his supporters
who storm the capitol and brutally
attack the law enforcement officers
protecting it i think it's important to
shout that out and call that out he even
attacked his own vice president for not
in his words having overturned the
election and it's just a reminder of how
unfit he is for office and it's telling
that even some of his closest allies
have rejected those remarks as
inappropriate in the days since as it
relates to the electoral count act as
you noted jeff in your question i mean
it is not a replacement and i think why
we keep saying that is because we don't
want anyone to suggest who supports it
that it's a replacement for the john
lewis voting rights act or other voting
rights legislation that has important
components of it that would provide a
basic baseline and important protections
for people across the country who are
trying to exercise their fundamental
right we've been open to and a part of
conversations about the electoral
account act we've never been opposed to
it we just don't want it to be a
replacement for
and and lastly at least six hbcus
received bomb threats today yeah the fbi
says it's aware of these threats and
it's coordinated with the local law
enforcement has the president been
briefed and uh do you have anything to
say about it from the podium
i will say that these are certainly
disturbing
and the white house is in touch with the
interagency partners including federal
law enforcement leadership on this we're
relieved to hear
that howard and bethune cookman
universities have been given the all
clear and will continue to monitor these
reports president is aware i don't
believe he's received a formal briefing
but he is aware of these reports and
obviously as you noted law enforcement
authorities would be running point
go ahead jeff thank you jen there was a
u.n security council meeting today yeah
russia's ambassador at that meeting said
that the west's assertion that russia
has amassed a hundred thousand troops on
the border has not been confirmed
and china at that meeting also said that
it did not view russia's troops as a
threat to ukraine wondering about your
the white house's response to those two
comments well those are also the two
countries that voted against the meeting
proceeding the only two right um
i would note that we have based the
information we have provided to all of
you on uh substantive reports out there
our own assessments our own uh uh
coordinated intelligence gathering with
our uh with our partners on the ground
uh so and those are assessments that are
as you know jeff are also made by the
europeans um now again uh russia has the
power they are the aggressor here they
have the power and ability to uh
de-escalate to pull their troops back
from the border to not push more troops
to belarus to take steps to de-escalate
the situation on the ground but we know
we see with our own eyes you have
heard members of our uh defense team our
secretary of defense as well as general
milley speak to this in very specific
detail as well as our u.n ambassador
this morning it is not our preference to
be having these conversations we'd
prefer there to be a de-escalatory
actions by the russians
china
and look i i think that uh i can't speak
for the motivation of the chinese uh
they can speak for that themselves
obviously we would encourage any country
in the world to be part of
an effort to de-escalate to uh protect
and respect the the sovereignty of
ukraine and to make clear that a global
value is uh not allowing one country to
invade and take land from another do you
have any more details on your plant and
post sanctions on russia's on the
kremlin's inner circle uh let me see
jeff i know there were some reports over
that about that over the weekend
that has been as it was back in 2014 as
i think you probably remember
a part of what we have been
considering um i can confirm we have
developed specific sanctions packages
for both russian elites and their family
members if russia further engage invades
ukraine these efforts are being pursued
in coordination with allies and partners
the individuals we've identified are in
or near the inner circle of the kremlin
and play a role in government decision
making or at a minimum complicit in the
kremlin's destabilizing behavior many of
these individuals are particularly
vulnerable targets because of their
deepened financial ties with the west
meaning they would be hurt by sanctions
that are tying them to western financial
systems uh i would also note that this
is just one piece of our effort to hit
russia from all angles and this is when
jake sullivan came here several weeks
ago and talked about how this will be
far above and beyond what we're
considering 2014 a lot of what we did in
2014 was around individuals right and
we're talking about major parts of the
financial system but there is a package
we have developed specific sanctions
packages for both russian elites and
their family members go ahead thank you
jim
um zooming out a bit
on ukraine okay more
um does the president consider as a risk
at the different simultaneous things
going on right now you've got north
korea
upping its missile game
uh you've got the
the taiwan straits probably has never
been more tense than it is now and of
course ukraine does he consider fear
that there's any link between these
things not in some kind of coordinated
master plan but that at least one of
those
you know each place is watching the
other and will take its cues
and then maybe how ukraine goes forward
could
provide a lesson to the to the other uh
challenges
well i would say one north korea has
been doing missile tests dozens of them
in prior administrations and obviously
we've spoken to it each time that that
has happened our door the door to
diplomacy remains open and we have
conveyed that clearly um we are very
careful not to combine all of these
pieces into one because they are all
different circumstances there is also if
i flip it on flip it a little bit i
would say a clear value that we need to
stand by which is the belief of the
united states and our nato partners uh
that and other countries of course
around the world that you can't just
stand by and accept one country trying
to invade and take land from another
country and this is also about
protecting the sovereignty of a country
and that is a value that's important to
stand by as well so as we are
as the president and other members of
our national security team are conveying
that very clearly privately and publicly
that's also sending a message to other
countries around the world if you look
at what president putin's stated
objectives are or his spokespeople i
guess i should say uh he wants to divide
the west he wants to divide nato the
opposite is happening there's been more
than 200 engagements with nato countries
we are united uh fiercely united um and
standing up to
what we see as aggressive behavior
bellicose rhetoric even as we're leaving
the door to diplomacy open
one on the olympics
does he um does the president have a
stand on
this debate over whether athletes should
be able to express
political or human rights or anything
non-sporting views at the olympics i
know the olympics has got some rules but
the chinese came out today with some
pretty uh tough statements
warning people not to step out of line
what would the president's reaction be
if an american athlete gets up on that
stand
says does something i think we spoke to
this last summer
and conveyed a support for freedom of
speech of individuals
what
just today we've heard russian diplomats
say see hysteria pr stunned megaphone
diplomacy to describe how the us has
been talking about what's going on there
you've all said policy is still
interested in that and that
it will have to shift from the we really
want to do this to
clearly they're not paying attention at
this point well i think what's important
to note here as our view is that the
door to diplomacy should always be open
uh and that is what the president
the the our secretary of state our
secretary of defense have been conveying
i think the state department confirmed
this morning that our secretary of state
will be talking with foreign minister
lavrov lee tomorrow that would be a next
step in our diplomatic efforts and
engagements here
um but i think we've also been very um
uh prioritized and focused on and you
saw our un ambassador do this in the at
the at the
session this morning calling out what we
see as misinformation and propaganda at
times
by russian leaders and others because
it's important for people to know and
understand what the facts are but
regardless of what people's public
rhetoric is it's our view that the door
to diplomacy should always be open and
ultimately the question here is about
what president putin is going to do so
we're always going to keep that door
open
and back to scotus just to try one more
time go ahead with judge hiles you had
within two hours of the event here with
justice breyer and the president you had
congressman clyburn obviously a very
close ally come out of very public push
for childs and then as mentioned earlier
you and senator grant do that
hard to think of two opposite folks the
number three house democrat like the
president of former judiciary committee
they're both from south carolina which
may be a factor
with the state but when you have when
you're talking about the bipartisan part
of it how much weight
might the president put on something
like that where you have again the
number three house democrat you have
lindsey graham
uniting for one person are very publicly
putting the pressure on almost
immediately to kind of nudge him in that
direction well i can only tell you what
how the president is approaching his
role here and uh through uh he is um
very familiar and has lived through
many confirmation processes and hearings
he takes his role very seriously and his
role is to pick
the most eminently qualified uh
credentialed uh black woman to serve
as the supreme court as a supreme court
justice a lifetime appointment uh it is
certainly encouraging we've seen the
comments of course of senator graham and
and congressman clyburn um we always
welcome agreements on anything in this
town
but the president's focus is not on
gaming out the process it's on picking
the right candidate
um so the the president today two two
topics for strong inflation the first
one the president told uh governors
today quote uh we've sent you a whole
hell of a lot of money and we're going
to send you more um the fed chairman
last week though said that the drop in
fiscal spending this year will help ease
inflation
so again what's the level of concern for
the president that more spending would
contribute to inflation well there is
still going to be a massive drop um this
year because of the end of a number of
programs so that doesn't that doesn't
change what the president um conveyed um
i don't i didn't see the totality of it
so i don't know what the full context of
it there are still of course programs
and requests that these governors have
whether it is help on covid uh or help
with specific small businesses and there
is still some targeted assistance that
leaders still want they need and we are
delivering from the federal government
but that doesn't change if you look at
the overarching graph of like how much
federal assistance is going that it's a
natural drop because of the end of a lot
of programs
so on the federal reserve nominees um
the federal reserve maintains this
independence
one of the pigs uh sarah bloom raskin is
the wife of representative jamie raskin
as you know it's been a while since i
had a seat so i get to ask about the
federal reserve now um
you know he was uh an impeachment
manager in the impeachment trial of a
republican president so ken does the
president believe she can keep that
independence from the fed
well i would also just i think she can
stand on her own qualifications not just
because she's a woman but because she's
done a lot in her career she has been
said by many to be the most qualified
person to be nominated to this role
which i think is probably more important
than who she's married to i would argue
she brings unprecedented experience to
this role and the support of economic
experts across the spectrum including
from the top economic adviser to former
president bush
she believes and she has said she
believes firmly in the independent role
of the federal reserve and will work in
concert with tara powell and her
colleagues to identify and mitigate a
range of risks
she is also
you know somebody who again as i
mentioned has a wealth of experience
that she would be
leaning into in this role
the u.s chamber of commerce sent a
letter to committee members there
calling into question her activism
related to regulations on where banks
could lend or should be able to limit
lending into certain industries
specifically
well let me know what a couple of others
have said the care the community banker
and former fed governor betsy duke the
characterization of sarah bloom raskin
is someone who will use the powers of
the fed for political purposes is simply
false i saw every day her commitment to
the fed's dual mandate former bush gea
chair glenn hubbard raskin brings a
wealth of experience to a federal former
independent community bankers of america
president ceo cam fine an outstanding
group of nominees i hope the senate will
confirm them as soon as possible and i
think just like any nominee she should
be judged by her qualifications she will
have a hearing coming up where i'm sure
she will
answer a range of questions uh but i
think her her background her credentials
her experience is uh is unquestionable
in terms of its preparedness for this
role so her husband being an impeachment
manager had nothing to do with that
again i would say that her experience
and her
impeccable credentials were the
determinant and her being nominated for
this role and i i think it's a little uh
questionable for anyone to raise
otherwise go ahead thank you jen uh the
administration is committed to the
release of
u.s citizens in held in iran
um can you update us if there's anything
new and whether the uh white house has
asked the qatari foreign minister to
mediate since he was recently in tehran
and i have another question sure um well
i would say obviously there's a range of
topics as i think we we briefed out to
you and we can talk about more about
that uh if you would like um that will
be discussed uh during the meeting this
afternoon um
there's no uh special coordination
between the united states and qatar on
this particular visit
about iran but of course there are a
range of topics including the nuclear
negotiations that could be a part of the
discussion so nothing on the release of
the hostages everything was reported
it's not correct well i i would say
again um i don't have anything more to
offer to you other than to say that um
they could talk about the iran nuclear
negotiations but there's no special
coordination plan for this trip
also the the houthis has attacked abu
dhabi um yesterday
uh while the israeli president was
meeting um you keep saying that you want
to protect your allies in the gulf but
practically how can you stop them from
escalating as we have seen in the last
few weeks
well i expect my colleague john kirby at
the pentagon may have more to say on
this but i can tell you that as to your
question about your the report uh u.s
military personnel responded to an
inbound missile threat on the uae this
involved the employment of patriot
interceptors
to coincidental efforts by the armed
forces of the uae uh i would say we are
working quite closely with them again my
colleague will have um more to speak to
uh but we are very focused on working
with them and defending against all
threats uh to their peoples and
territories
good shelby thanks i got two um nikki
haley and senator rich wrote an open
letter to you olympic athletes this
morning
warning of a high risk and potentially
doing its political environment is
president biden at all concerned for the
safety of american athletes competing
well i would say first that we are very
focused on the safety of american
athletes
and as you know unrelated all related i
guess we made a decision not to send a
delegation it was not related to that it
was related to
our
concerns about prc's ongoing genocide
and crimes against humanity and xinjiang
and other human rights abuses i just
wanted to note that for the record
but in terms of athletes
we do everything possible to work in
coordination with the u.s olympic
committee we're providing consular and
security services to our athletes
coaches trainers and staff as we do for
all u.s citizens overseas additionally
we expect the prc to ensure the safety
and well-being of our athletes they have
our full support we are 100
behind them we've also provided the us
olympic and paralympic committee and
corporate sponsors with briefings uh as
well and we will continue to work in
lockstep with them and then going back
to crime i know you noted the president
is you know not for defunding the police
he has initiatives on combating crime
but we are seeing crime surge in major
cities and the president's poll numbers
on the topic you know there was a is to
get an approval rating on crime was at
36 and one december poll
does that indicate to the white house at
all that americans feel democrats are
out of touch when it comes to safety or
criminal justice and you know what's the
administration's take away to
these numbers and the rising crime
i think we all agree or should agree
that violent crime is a serious problem
we actually saw a record jump in murders
in 2020 under the former president
and there hasn't been new fbi nationwide
data that has been released to date
there has been city some city data of
course which is important to focus on uh
and talk about uh our view is that
instead of turning this into a political
football we need to be focused from the
beginning of the president's time
all of his time in office on reducing
crime and keeping our community safe and
that's why he's been a long time
advocate for more accountable community
policing that's why he has uh supported
and advocated for additional funding for
proven community programs to reduce
crime why he's working to crack down on
rogue gun dealers who sell firearms to
criminals and why he's taken executive
action to crack down on ghost guns
so his objective is to work with
democrats republicans mayors local
leaders to work to address what we've
seen as increases in crime in some areas
but i would just note that nationwide
there has been an increase in crime over
the past few years
oh good i'm sorry go ahead uh yeah the
governors were just out of the states
just a minute ago after meeting with the
president
they said their biggest
message to
the president and the administration is
they want flexibility in how they spend
these monies what can the administration
do or what are you doing which money
just requires
infrastructure
and also a cobian relief bill
they want more flexibility in how they
can spend that sure um well i would say
first on infrastructure we just
published this massive booklet with the
intention of providing a bunch of
guidance to governors state and local
electeds communities about how they can
apply for funding it goes through
different grant programs so different
programs work differently uh some of it
as i think we've noted in the past has
been against some of the most
structurally challenged bridges for
example which will take some time but
there are just different ranges of
programs that come from different
agencies
obviously if there are lead pipes in
their state or communities or schools
those are things we're going to replace
that's pretty clear but there is a lot
of hopefully comprehensive information
in this lengthy booklet about how our
book it's a big book uh about how to
apply for grants uh a follow-up for how
to ask questions uh as they come up as
needed in terms of coveted relief funds
i mean we have what i'd really have to
dig into more specifics of what they're
looking for there have been areas of
some flexibility in terms of how funding
has been spent for schools or how
funding has been spent for
local community programs throughout the
course of time like through the american
rescue plan and others so i'd have to
look at the greater context of what
their exact issue is okay and the final
question any is what is the federal
government going to do to supply or any
supplies going to the northeast states
that just got hit by but the blizzard
so we work very closely with state local
leaders to respond to natural disasters
of course including
storms typically those requests need to
come first from governors in the states
i can check with fema and see if there's
any specific requests that has come in
or what needs that have that have arisen
uh in in in the days since the storm i
mean days it's not been that many days
but you got what i'm saying we'll see if
we can get more details too after three
go ahead uh on infrastructure
uh
on the topic of the sky book i actually
just did a report in the state i cover
california yeah and there were
a ton of questions about just the the
state portion the formula fund portion
yeah that the state already knows he's
gonna get fitted
so many questions about how that's
supposed to go out yeah
how
does the white house plan to sort of
oversee all of that distribution and
sort of make sure that the money is
having its intended effect sure you mean
to avoid waste fraud and abuse or to
abuse but you know given that states
will have a lot of discretion on how
these funds are spent just in terms of
the ultimate outcome being so close sure
through very close consultation i mean
you saw the president have a meeting
with his infrastructure task force on
the day of his one year anniversary that
shows how important uh the
implementation of this bill is to the
president the um the objective that what
we're trying to do with the publication
of this book is to provide clear
criteria as a baseline obviously to
build questions off of and to have
follow-ups but i think from here what
the president always says when i'm in
meetings with him with mitch landrieu is
a big part of our jobs is you know
spending hours a day calling mayors
calling governors seeing what local uh
what questions come from local electeds
that's the role he played as vice
president and that's what his
expectation is so this this big book is
is a is a base that will hopefully help
answer a range of questions but
different programs are being implemented
by different agencies even as they're
being coordinated by here so really
depends on the program implementation uh
to where those questions should be
directed and in terms of the american
people how do you intend to ensure that
the average american ends up knowing
what the impact of this bill was are you
guys going to do signage the way we've
sort of seen in the past with some of
these big initiatives i think there will
be some branding around the
infrastructure implementation that the
american people should be able to see
and lastly you know it's still up near
but in california there's sort of a push
to get a single-payer
health plan across the state is that
something that you think the federal
government could end up being able to
interface with and and something that
you know california were to proceed uh
you guys
would welcome
in terms of interface in what way you
know that if the state were to implement
the sort of single-payer plan work with
everything else you guys have in the
healthcare ecosystem
we would of course work to to coordinate
uh with any state uh but i don't have
any more details at this point in time
we'll wait to see what they do thanks
everyone
you